hey guys I'm Jess McDonald it is monday
the 6th of January and you're watching
our third games got news show of the
year I think it's customary to stop
counting now first off the very patient
fans of daisy are apparently also very
devoted fans in that the game has sold
over 400,000 copies in its first week of
release bohemia interactive's open-world
zombie apocalypse hit 88 thousand copies
sold in 12 hours and then 170 2500 in
the first full day the game is currently
a part of steam's early access scheme
and is still only in alsace next up
microsoft have yet again started the
pissing contest of who sold more
consoles aimed at last year 3 million
Xbox ones were sold through to consumers
use of Mary publicize the bigger in a
statement which is sure to eventually
push Sony to reveal their uncomfortable
figures for the period and then start
the cycle all over again until
presumably they'll eventually be touting
units sold between 156 p.m. on January
the second to 1132 a.m. the following
day are you interested to hear so need
to reply on this one or could you get
less which console is beating the other
at any random point in time let me know
the steam machines are coming and
they're kind of expensive or at least
one of them is PC manufacturer digital
storms offering is landing with a shop
nineteen hundred dollar price tag but
it's called the bolt to clearly way
better than the bolt one and as a fancy
red lightning bolt on it the small form
factor pc will let you jewel boot
windows and steam OS a second model
which will put you two thousand five
hundred and eighty-four dollars out of
pocket comes with an nvidia geforce gtx
780ti graphics card 120 gigabyte SSD 16
gigabytes of ram and a one terabyte hard
drive alongside a built-in 240
millimeter liquid cooling systems last
up nvidia has a mobile processor that
can outperform the ps3 and the xbox 360
while although their eight-year-old
consult is pretty cool the nifty piece
of hardware announced at CES is called
the Tegra k1 and is based on Nvidia's
kepler architecture
show which is also employed within its
latest desktop geforce graphics cards in
video showed off the chips ability to
perform effects including HDR lighting
particles remaining and the ability to
run Unreal Engine 4 is the evolution of
mobile technology something you expected
to come this far this soon and you even
into mobile gaming you can let me know
in the section allocated to commenting
or almost whether where I'm access
McDonald's there's our most other things
that I cared about today but be sure to
leave me all your favorite stories in
the comments below I will be back same
time and place tomorrow so I'll catch
you again soon